una alfombra roja se extendió en berlín
cuando narendra modi comenzó su visita
de tres días a europa el primer ministro
indio fue recibido calurosamente por el
canciller alemán olaf scholz con ambos
líderes como presidiendo las estas
consultas entre sus respectivos
gobiernos además de un compromiso con la
energía verde el tema principal de las
conversaciones fue ucrania si la guerra
y los brutales ataques contra la
población civil de ucrania demuestran lo
desenfrenada que ha sido rusia al violar
los principios fundamentales de la carta
de naciones unidas
sin embargo el tema ha provocado la ira
en cuanto a la posición de indias sobre
la guerra nueva delhi que durante
décadas se abasteció de armas rusas se
ha negado hasta ahora a denunciar las
acciones de vladimir putin y la invasión
de ucrania y creen que sangre arancegui
al comienzo de la crisis en ucrania
pedimos inmediatamente un alto el fuego
y subrayamos que el diálogo era la única
forma de resolver el conflicto creemos
que ninguna parte puede salir victoriosa
de esta guerra todos sufrirán pérdidas y
por eso estamos a favor de la paz
al contrario que europa india también ha
aumentado considerablemente las
importaciones de petróleo ruso desde con
considerables descuentos proporcionados
por moscú también se ha hablado de que
las empresas indias están aprovechando
la brecha que ha quedado en el mercado
ya que una delegación de exportadores se
dirige a la capital rusa a finales de
este mes en busca de oportunidades
comerciales pero las discusiones del
lunes han servido para reforzar los
lazos económicos alemania prometió 10
mil millones de euros más para la
cooperación bilateral con india el
siguiente paso de modi en su corta gira
es una visita a dinamarca donde estarán
presentes otros líderes escandinavos el
destino final es francia donde se
reunirá con el presidente manuel bacón
para tener conversaciones cara a cara en
parís